Shure: 不能违法呀你
Shure: You can't be illegal.
Katrina: 我唱的是国歌
Katrina: I'm singing the national anthem.
Katrina: 中华人民共和国国歌
Katrina: The national anthem of the People's Republic of China.
Katrina: 没有唱别的歌
Katrina: I'm not singing any other song.
Katrina: 我那那同学要来
Katrina: My classmate is coming.
Katrina: 那同学他
Katrina: That classmate.
Katrina: 我问他带不带吉他来
Katrina: I asked if he's bringing his guitar.
Katrina: 让他上来秀一个
Katrina: Let him show off a bit.
Shure: 这不就有吉他给给他了吗
Shure: Isn't there a guitar here for him?
Katrina: 他有自己的琴
Katrina: He has his own guitar.
Katrina: 还有电吉他
Katrina: And an electric guitar.
Shure: 北邮这样的人我都会认识的
Shure: I know people like this at Beiyou.
Katrina: 另一个
Katrina: Another one.
Shure: 是我知道
Shure: Yes, I know.
Shure: 我说只要
Shure: I mean, as long as.
Shure: 那个会吉他的我应该是都认识
Shure: I should know everyone who can play the guitar.
Shure: 他叫什么什么
Shure: What's his name?
Katrina: 谁啊
Katrina: Who?
Alice:你是哪个学院的
Alice: Which college are you from?
Shure: 我我是国际学院的
Shure: I'm from the International College.
Katrina: 你问哪一个
Katrina: Who are you asking about?
Katrina: 男嘉宾啊
Katrina: Male guest, huh
Shure: 我说那个事会吉它的那个
Shure: I mean the guy who plays guitar
Alice:啊什么你是你是哪个学院
Alice: Oh, which college are you from?
Shure: 国际学院
Shure: International College
Alice:国际
Alice: International
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Shure: 就是那种中外合作的那个
Shure: It's like a joint program between China and foreign countries
Katrina: 那个弹吉他那个啊
Katrina: The one who plays guitar, right?
Katrina: 弹吉他那是济南大学
Katrina: The guitar guy is from Jinan University
Katrina: 然后我们俩保研认识的
Katrina: We met during our grad school applications
Katrina: 然后他在清华实习
Katrina: And he interned at Tsinghua
Shure: 啊嗨我以为那是北邮的呢
Shure: Oh, I thought he was from BUPT
Katrina: 北邮那不会
Katrina: No, not BUPT
Katrina: 北邮那工作狂啊
Katrina: BUPT people are workaholics
Alice:你认识你的上一界吗
Alice: Do you know your seniors?
Shure: 我认识应该
Shure: I should, I think
Katrina: 你是
Alice:我不是
Alice: No, I'm not
Katrina: 你是
Alice:嗯哦
Alice: Hmm, oh
Katrina: 你是
Katrina: 那他是那个女生是
Katrina: Then that girl is from
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: 我搞混了
Katrina: I got it mixed up
Katrina: 还是搞一首热场歌的音乐
Katrina: Let's play a warm-up song
Shure: 一个安静的晚上
Shure: A quiet evening
Tasha:差不多可以了
Tasha: That should be good enough
Katrina: 你能夹吗
Katrina: Can you clamp it?
Katrina: 我当时跟我的室友去KTV唱这首歌
Katrina: I went to KTV with my roommate to sing this song
Katrina: 可搞笑了
Katrina: It was so funny
Katrina: 许嵩最近在武汉开演唱会
Katrina: Xu Song recently had a concert in Wuhan
Katrina: 这两天
Katrina: Just a few days ago
Katrina: 谢冰竹唱吗
Katrina: Is Xie Bingzhu singing?
Katrina: 谢冰竹
Katrina: Xie Bingzhu
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know
Katrina: 把他拉上吧
Katrina: Let's bring him on
Katrina: 不然就我俩
Katrina: Otherwise, it'll just be the two of us
Katrina: 给人会笑场
Katrina: People will laugh
Shure: 搞
Shure: Let's do it
Katrina: 这要唱素颜吗
Katrina: Should we sing "Plain Face"?
Katrina: 但确实是一首国民歌曲
Katrina: But it really is a national song.
Shure: 变成情歌对唱了是吧
Shure: It turned into a love duet, right?
Jake:对感情你
Jake: Yeah, about feelings.
Jake:两个人唱是吧
Jake: Two people singing, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 这是分男女生
Katrina: It's split into male and female parts.
Katrina: 就是许嵩跟一个人
Katrina: It's Xu Song and someone.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:哦哦哦我知道
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, I know.
Shure: 我一对4唱好吧哈哈哈
Shure: I'll sing one against four, okay? Haha.
Katrina: 你1对4唱
Katrina: You sing one against four?
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 揉就这面试要做什么
Katrina: By the way, what do we need to do for the interview?
Katrina: 明天
Katrina: Tomorrow?
Jake:呃现在做做麻薯
Jake: Uh, let's make some mochi now.
Katrina: 哇每天晚上都有加餐哎
Katrina: Wow, we have extra meals every night.
Katrina: 好幸福啊
Katrina: So happy.
Jake:确实比较
Jake: Indeed, quite.
Katrina: 麻薯好像可以放好几天哎
Katrina: Mochi can last for a few days, right?
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Katrina: 哦原来麻薯是这样做的嗯
Katrina: Oh, so that's how you make mochi.
Katrina: 感觉你在这几天也修炼了不少技能
Katrina: It feels like you've learned a lot of skills in these few days.
Jake:确实确实
Jake: Indeed, indeed.
Shure: 你回去直接可以新加坡
Shure: When you go back, you can go straight to Singapore.
Shure: 新加坡
Shure: Singapore.
Jake:对对对新加坡开店对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, open a store in Singapore.
Katrina: 新加坡开一个cake cake店
Katrina: Open a cake shop in Singapore.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 就叫EGO
Shure: Call it EGO.
Katrina: EGO cake
Katrina: EGO cake.
Jake:哈哈哈EGO cake可以可以可以
Jake: Haha, EGO cake, sure, sure.
Jake:EGO Bakery可以可以
Jake: EGO Bakery, sure, sure.
Jake:然后所有加热材料都是显卡
Jake: And all the heating materials are graphics cards.
Jake:就主打显卡
Jake: Just focus on graphics cards.
Katrina: 一个蛋糕换一张显卡
Katrina: Trade one cake for one graphics card.
Katrina: 一个一个显卡换一张蛋糕
Katrina: One graphics card for one cake.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:这个可以这个可以
Jake: This works, this works.
Jake:这个我喜欢我靠
Jake: I like this, damn.
Katrina: 定一下
Katrina: Let's set it.
Jake:哎呀我去
Jake: Oh my goodness
Katrina: 你最拿手的吧
Katrina: This is your specialty, right?
Katrina: 就是不用看谱的
Katrina: You don't even need to look at the sheet music.
Katrina: 你有推荐不
Katrina: Do you have any recommendations?
Katrina: 稍微热热场子
Katrina: Just to liven up the atmosphere a bit.
Katrina: 呃那个你要跳舞吗
Katrina: Uh, do you want to dance?
Katrina: 其实人多唱应该还行
Katrina: Actually, singing with a crowd should be fine.
Katrina: 能唱上去吗
Katrina: Can you hit those notes?
Shure: 女朋友会易眼前
Shure: My girlfriend will be like
Shure: 咦又唱这个破歌
Shure: "Ugh, this song again?"
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 行那换一个
Katrina: Okay, let's pick another one.
Shure: 没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Alice:你女朋友会来吗
Alice: Is your girlfriend coming?
Shure: 会吧应该
Shure: She should be.
Katrina: 那把她喊上来一起唱
Katrina: Then call her up to sing with us.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 别别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Katrina: 你女朋友是i人吗
Katrina: 你女朋友是i人
Shure: 我也是i人
Katrina: 哼哼
Katrina: Hmm, hmm.
Shure: 就我意的浓度不高你知道吗
Shure: It's just that my feelings aren't that intense, you know?
Katrina: 找你了
Katrina: Got it.
Katrina: 你们东北i人是这样
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey
Shure: 没事他那个去
Shure: It's okay, he's just
Shure: 卫卫生那什么的
Shure: dealing with some hygiene stuff.
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure: 那个杨老板
Shure: Jake
Shure: 把那个手机号给尼蔻斯发一下呗
Shure: Can you send Nicous that phone number?
Shure: 路亚的
Shure: Luya's number.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Shure: 把路亚的手机号给那个那谁发一下
Shure: Send Luya's number to, you know, that guy.
Jake:手机号啊
Jake: The phone number?
Shure: 他联系不到路亚现在
Shure: He can't reach Luya right now.
Jake:OK行
Jake: Okay, sure.
Shure: 好
Shure: Great.
Katrina: 不行
Katrina: No way.
Katrina: 不能唱情歌
Katrina: We can't sing love songs.
Katrina: 为什么
Katrina: Why?
Shure: 咋还在这
Shure: Why are you still here?
Katrina: 呃
Katrina: Uh...
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 唱素颜多那个
Katrina: Singing without makeup is so...
Katrina: 我也是被图书馆30秒弄过的人
Katrina: I've been kicked out of the library for 30 seconds before.
Katrina: 好吧不能这样
Katrina: Okay, can't do it like this.
Katrina: 换一首嗨一点的
Katrina: Let's switch to a more upbeat song.
Katrina: 刚刚有听到一首歌陶哲比较简单的歌
Katrina: Just heard a simple song by David Tao.
Katrina: 比较温馨的一首歌
Katrina: It's a pretty heartwarming song.
Katrina: 不知道难不难
Katrina: Not sure if it's hard or not.
Katrina: 你可以听一下
Katrina: You can listen to it.
Shure: 绿色的
Shure: The green one?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 之前有一首哦
Katrina: There was one before.
Katrina: 但是没看到
Katrina: But I didn't see it.
Katrina: 是一个英文歌的
Katrina: It was an English song.
Katrina: 保护环境
Katrina: About protecting the environment.
Katrina: 这一首比较和平的全世界会唱
Katrina: This one is more peaceful, the whole world can sing it.
Katrina: 世界地球日是唱什么歌我想唱一句试试
Katrina: What song do we sing for Earth Day? I want to try singing a line.
Katrina: 刚打开小红书就刷到了南阳理工大学
Katrina: Just opened Xiaohongshu and saw Nanyang Technological University.
Katrina: 满足了我对大学的一切想象
Katrina: It fulfilled all my imagination of a university.
Shure: 我给谢彬竹拿把伞下雨了
Shure: I'm bringing an umbrella to Xie Binzhu, it's raining.
Katrina: 下雨了吗
Katrina: Is it raining?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 来抱着他吧
Shure: Here, hold him.
Katrina: 我装一下我装一下
Katrina: Let me act, let me act.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 我要摆拍了你赶紧走吧
Katrina: I'm going to pose for a photo, you go ahead.
Shure: 你装个逼 好的
Shure: You pose, okay.
Katrina: 啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Ah hahaha
Shure: 非常快乐的
Shure: Very happy.
Shure: 有一首歌叫做水手公园
Shure: There's a song called Sailor Park.
Katrina: 没听过
Katrina: Never heard of it.
Katrina: 要不就唱NEW BOY
Katrina: Why don't we sing NEW BOY?
Shure: 行那就NEW BOY
Shure: Sure, let's do NEW BOY.
Katrina: 试一下
Katrina: Let's try it.
Katrina: 不知道歌词
Katrina: Don't know the lyrics.
Katrina: 不知道歌词我看一下
Katrina: Don't know the lyrics, let me check.
Katrina: 你可以不用看谱啊
Katrina: You don't need to look at the sheet music.
Katrina: 都
Katrina: All
Katrina: 唱唯一哈
Katrina: Sing the only one, huh
Katrina: 北京民谣摇滚第九名
Katrina: Ninth place in Beijing folk rock
Jake:给你个任务
Jake: I've got a task for you
Jake:去接路亚吧
Jake: Go pick up Luya
Alice:在哪啊
Alice: Where is she?
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go
Jake: :她眼镜是在下面吗
Jake: Are her glasses down there?
Alice:这个吧
Alice: This one?
Jake:唉谢彬竹接到了吗
Jake: Hey, did you pick up Xie Binzhu?
Jake:我我给你
Jake: I’ll give you
Jake:你去拿充电宝
Jake: You go get the power bank
Alice:拿几个啊
Alice: How many should I get?
Jake:在这边
Jake: Over here
Jake:拿一个
Jake: Just one
Jake:拿一个就够你拿个高的
Jake: One is enough, get a tall one
Jake:40吧 他没这么高呢那个不是更高吗
Jake: 40, it’s not that tall, isn’t that one taller?
Jake:那个后面的
Jake: The one at the back
Jake:我靠不行那就拿40走
Jake: No way, just take the 40
Alice:我去哪里接她
Alice: Where do I pick her up?
Jake:啊你跟谢彬竹走
Jake: Ah, you go with Xie Binzhu
Alice:那我换个鞋吧
Alice: Then I’ll change my shoes
Tasha:开车你好像可以不换鞋
Tasha: You can drive without changing shoes
Alice:开车去的吗
Alice: We’re driving?
Tasha:是开车去吗
Tasha: Are we driving?
Tasha:打车去
Tasha: Take a taxi
Alice:这么远吗
Alice: Is it that far?
Jake:没有很远就是安全一点
Jake: Not really, just to be safe
Alice:那我不换鞋了
Alice: Then I won’t change shoes
Jake:你不用换鞋了
Jake: You don’t need to change shoes
Nicous: hello 你怎么出来了
Nicous: Hello, why are you out?
Alice:让我跟你一块
Alice: They told me to go with you
Nicous: 你也跟我一块
Nicous: You’re coming with me too?
Alice:也
Alice: Yeah
Nicous: 也 她刚和我说的
Nicous: Yeah, she just told me
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Nicous: 他刚和我说的
Nicous: He just told me
Alice:谁
Alice: Who?
Nicous: 杨老板
Nicous: Jake
Alice:嗯
Alice: Oh
Alice:村头
Alice: At the village entrance
Nicous: 巷口
Nicous: At the alley entrance
Alice:说这是村口因该也没什么
Alice: Saying this is the village entrance shouldn't be a big deal
Alice:你可以让我回去拿个东西吗
Alice: Can you let me go back to get something?
Alice:他快到了吗
Alice: Is he almost here?
Alice:拿个东西
Alice: Getting something
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
Alice:吓死我了
Alice: Scared me to death
Alice:我以为断了呢
Alice: I thought it was broken
Alice:ok
Alice: Okay
Alice:呦
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:你今天没开车吗
Alice: Didn't you drive today?
Nicous: 那个车是我们租的，就只租那两天
Alice:哦
Nicous: 你现在是大四啊？
Alice:你猜
Alice: Take a guess
Alice:那你就忘了吧
Alice: Then just forget it
Alice:我是盐吧
Alice: Am I salt?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes
Alice:什么不可能
Alice: What's impossible?
Alice:所以我是盐巴
Alice: So I am salt
Alice:你是大四
Alice:你是要申请
Alice: Are you applying
Alice:结婚了
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Nicous: 喂 喂 喂
Nicous: Hello, hello, hello
Nicous: 马上过去了 刚才那个
Nicous: I'm heading over now, just now that
Nicous: 导航导了半个小时快
Nicous: The navigation took almost half an hour
Nicous: 耽误了点时间
Nicous: Delayed a bit
Nicous: 还真是
Nicous: Really
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Ah
Alice:她已经打完了吗
Alice: Did she already finish?
Nicous: 现在马上还有
Nicous: Right now there's still
Nicous: 还有
Nicous: Still
Nicous: 还有三四分钟就见到她了
Nicous: We'll see her in three or four minutes
Alice:她已经打完了针在等我们了吗
Alice: Did she already finish the shot and is waiting for us?
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Yeah
Alice:她已经打完针在等我们了吗
Alice: Did she already finish the shot and is waiting for us?
Alice:我问她在哪
Alice: I'll ask her where she is
Alice:你的眼镜
Alice:OK
Lucia: 啊我的是吧
Alice:是的
Lucia: OK
Alice:打针疼吗挺疼的吧
Alice: Does the shot hurt? It must hurt quite a bit, right?
Lucia:呃有点
Lucia: Uh, a bit
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:狂犬疫苗是挺疼的
Alice: The rabies vaccine really hurts.
Lucia: 对
Lucia:我本来想着也没啥事
Lucia: I thought it wouldn't be a big deal.
Lucia:但是我家里人觉得不是很放心
Lucia: But my family wasn't very reassured.
Nicous: 你出血了吗，那个医生咋讲
Lucia:啊啥
Lucia: Ah, what?
Nicous: 那医生怎么说啊
Nicous: What did the doctor say?
Lucia:呃
Lucia: Uh...
Lucia:医生说就是就是它这个红的地方比较小
Lucia: The doctor said that the red area is pretty small.
Lucia:所就他说就是它很难判断
Lucia: So he said it's hard to tell.
Lucia:皮肤它倒底破了没有
Lucia: Whether the skin is actually broken or not.
Lucia:因为说如果说这种破损很小的话
Lucia: Because if the damage is very small...
Lucia:可能就是你现在你这个皮肤表层已经就是不疼了
Lucia:但是你就是要判断他破没破
Lucia:是你在刚被就是就是咬到的时候
Lucia:你就要拿酒精什么的擦一下
Lucia:看看有没有刺痛感
Alice:恩
Lucia:但现在时间已经过了，所以就是
Lucia:没办法判断的话就可以还是打一个吧
Alice:皮比较浅可能
Alice: The skin might be shallow.
Alice:到现在已经长好了是吧
Alice: Has it healed by now?
Lucia:对对对 但是假如真的破了的话就是并不会
Lucia: Yeah, but if it was really broken, it wouldn't have.
Lucia:万一只是在表皮进不去
Lucia: In case it was just on the surface and didn't go in.
Lucia:所以我觉得保险起见
Lucia: So, to be safe...
Lucia:因为我就是我还专门去那个咖啡馆问了一下
Lucia: I even went to the café to ask about it.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia:我说就是这个小狗有没有疫苗本
Lucia: I asked if the puppy had a vaccine record.
Lucia:你给我看一下
Lucia: Show it to me.
Lucia:然后他们说是那个狗舍打的疫苗
Lucia: They said the vaccine was done at the kennel.
Lucia:所以他们这没有疫苗本
Lucia: So they don't have a record there.
Lucia:但是有那个什么疫苗瓶但是好像
Lucia: But they have the vaccine bottle, but it seems...
Lucia:就是之前已经扔掉了
Lucia: They threw it away earlier.
Lucia:然后我不是特别放心然后
Lucia: So, I wasn't very reassured and...
Lucia:那个地方一直有点红
Lucia: The area was still a bit red.
Lucia:反正然后我就是觉得哎呀
Lucia: Anyway, I just thought, well...
Alice:保险
Alice: Better safe.
Lucia:对 保险起见
Lucia: Yeah, better safe than sorry.
Lucia:没关系 问题不大
Lucia: It's okay, it's not a big problem.
Lucia:只不过就是我后面还要打两针
Lucia: It's just that I still need two more shots.
Lucia:哎
Lucia: Sigh.
Alice:那你记得记好时间
Alice: Remember to keep track of the time.
Lucia:以后也不能喝酒了
Lucia: I can't drink alcohol anymore.
Lucia:你们坐车过来的话是不是有点远
Lucia: Is it a bit far for you guys to come by car?
Alice:不太远呀
Alice: Not too far.
Alice:嗨呀你是怎么来的
Alice: How did you get here?
Lucia:我走过来的
Lucia: I walked here.
Lucia:就是从咱们那走到那个
Lucia: I walked from our place to...
Lucia:就是那个那
Lucia: You know, that place...
Lucia:那算什么呀
Lucia: What's that about?
Lucia:卫生所挺好挺近的其实
Lucia: The health center is actually pretty good and close by.
Lucia:就是
Lucia: It's just that
Alice:可能可能走车的话就是有点点绕
Alice: Maybe taking the car is a bit roundabout.
Lucia:对对因为可能小路车没法过就只能人行
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, because the small paths can't accommodate cars, so you have to walk.
Lucia:我是那个啥
Lucia: I'm that...
Lucia:咱们
Lucia: We...
Lucia:吃完饭之后
Lucia: After we ate,
Lucia:就我给我问了一下我们家人
Lucia: I asked my family about it.
Lucia:觉得有没有必要
Lucia: Whether it's necessary or not.
Lucia:打一下我妈是他朋友养的猫就是那个
Lucia: My mom's friend's cat, you know, that cat...
Lucia:他他朋友养的猫就有就是给猫打过疫苗了
Lucia: Her friend's cat has been vaccinated.
Lucia:猫抓到之后也就去打了这个疫苗了
Lucia: After it scratched, they went and got the vaccine.
Lucia:然后他说觉得还是打下比较放心
Lucia: And she said it's better to be safe and get the shot.
Lucia:尤其这个不是自己自己家养的
Lucia: Especially since it's not our own pet.
Lucia:尤其还是别人家养的
Lucia: It's someone else's pet.
Lucia:然后我就想着我就去一下吧
Lucia: So I thought I'd just go.
Lucia:然后我就出门
Lucia: And then I headed out.
Lucia:我先去了咖啡馆然后问了一下之后
Lucia: I first went to the café and asked around,
Lucia:然后那个到了那条路再接着往前走
Lucia: Then walked down that road and kept going straight.
Lucia:再拐一下
Lucia: Then turned.
Lucia:然后再拐一下就到那个卫生所了
Lucia: And turned again to reach the health center.
Lucia:我本来还想着应该挺快
Lucia: I thought it would be quick.
Lucia:然后我刚好就趁这个时间打完回去
Lucia: And I could get the shot and come back in time.
Lucia:大家可以开始录
Lucia: So you could start recording.
Lucia:结果他稍微慢一点点
Lucia: But it took a bit longer.
Lucia:因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia:sorrysorry
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Lucia:sorry sorry
Alice:你敲门的时候我以为是第二早上
Alice: When you knocked on the door, I thought it was the next morning.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈第二早上
Lucia: Hahahahaha, the next morning?
Alice:我以为今周六了
Alice: It's already Saturday.
Lucia:一觉睡到第二天
Lucia: Slept straight through to the next day.
Alice:我今天晚上巨困
Alice: I'm super tired tonight.
Lucia:我也好困
Lucia: I'm so tired too.
Alice:我昨天烧烤我太废力气了我感觉我
Alice: The BBQ yesterday wore me out, I feel drained.
Alice:一下被榨干了
Alice: Completely exhausted.
Lucia:我知道这个车走的是哪条道
Lucia: I know which route the car is taking.
Lucia:我刚在高德地图上
Lucia: I just checked on Gaode Map.
Lucia:看那个位置的时候
Lucia: When looking at that spot,
Lucia:我大概知道这个路线
Lucia: I kind of know the route.
Lucia:哎还得还是得自己查地图
Lucia: But I still need to check the map myself.
Lucia:我前几天根本就不认路
Lucia: A few days ago, I had no sense of direction.
Lucia:今天一查之后我觉得我已经对这片的
Lucia: After checking today, I think I have a general idea
Lucia:大概方位门清了
Alice:几只狗狗在这里玩
Alice: A few dogs are playing here.
Lucia:我现在有点PTSD了
Lucia: I'm feeling a bit PTSD right now.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia:啊没事
Lucia: Oh, it's nothing.
Lucia:我在想后面的一个
Lucia: I was thinking about something else.
Alice:有什么可以帮你的吗
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: No, no, it's fine.
Lucia:不是特别那个啥
Lucia: It's not that big of a deal.
Alice:哎呦垫死我了
Alice: Ouch, that hurt me.
Alice:谢彬竹你那个彬是三点水那个彬吗
Alice: Xie Binzhu, is your "Bin" the one with three water dots?
Alice:竹子的竹
Alice: And "zhu" as in bamboo?
Alice:这有什么含义吗
Alice: Does it have any special meaning?
Jake:忙着唱别的歌去了
Jake: Busy singing other songs.
Alice:哦确实
Alice: Oh, indeed.
Lucia:哎哇
Lucia: Wow.
Alice:看这个名字我就在想这个水木属性
Alice: Looking at this name, I was thinking of its water and wood elements.
Lucia:我之前还以为你是两点水的那个冰
Lucia: I used to think your "Bin" was the one with two water dots.
Alice:那你是不是起名的时候给你算过呀
Alice: Did you consult someone when you were named?
Lucia:三几几
Lucia: Three... something.
Lucia:哈哈几几几
Lucia: Haha, something something.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:至少我也得记住三个数是吧
Lucia: At least I need to remember three numbers, right?
Alice:缺水缺木
Alice: Lacking water and wood.
Lucia:嗯
Nicous: 你会算命吗
Alice:我需要一点点点点八字
Nicous: 这个是不是要看手
Nicous: 还是要看什么生 出生时间吧
Alice:恩
Lucia: 你这是蓝莓味的吗
Nicous: 恩
Alice:木生火 火生土
Alice: Wood creates fire, fire creates earth.
Alice:土生金
Alice: Earth creates metal.
Alice:金生水
Alice:那那个手链是不是也是按这个选的呀
Alice: So, was your bracelet chosen based on this too?
Alice:就选黑色的
Alice: You chose black, right?
Nicous: 手链我女朋友编的，我不知道
Alice:但是黑色确实是补水的
Alice: But black does indeed replenish water.
Lucia:他只能等待他找你哈
Lucia: He can only wait for you to find him.
Alice:我一直手机在静音
Alice: My phone's been on silent the whole time.
Alice:谁都别想
Lucia:谁都别想找到你
Lucia: No one can find you then.
Alice:对
Lucia:那快递小哥给你送快递的时候
Lucia: Even the delivery guy can't deliver your package.
Alice:一般我又不送货上门
Alice: Normally, I don't do home deliveries.
Alice:都是到驿站之类的
Alice: It's always to a pickup station or something.
Lucia:找我干啥
Lucia: Why are you looking for me?
Lucia:晚上还怪冷的
Lucia: It's still quite cold at night.
Lucia:我甚至还穿了一个厚外套
Lucia: I'm even wearing a thick coat.
Alice:直接开门
Alice: Just open the door.
Lucia:看我说的完全正确吧
Lucia: See, I was totally right.
Lucia:三几几几几几哈哈哈
Lucia: Three something something something, haha.
露丝:哎他们都在干啥
Lucia: Hey, what are they all doing?
露丝:都在二楼哎
Lucia: They're all on the second floor.
露丝:我说这直接一按就开了
Lucia: I told you, just press it and it opens.
Jake:哎呀回来啦
Jake: Oh, you're back!
露丝:啊咽来好
Lucia: Ah, you're back, great.
Alice:你进来了吗
Alice: Did you come in?
Alice:要上楼吗
Alice: Do you want to go upstairs?
Jake:上吧
Jake: Let's go up.
Alice:上吧
Alice: Let's go up.
Jake:外面下雨了吗
Jake: Is it raining outside?
露丝:没下呢
Lucia: Not yet.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Alice:这是干嘛
Alice: What's going on here?
Jake:来坐
Jake: Come, have a seat.
Jake:大伙现在在讨论
Jake: Everyone is discussing right now.
Jake:哎最后一天唱点啥
Jake: What to sing on the last day.
Jake:这咱就不跳舞了
Jake: We're not dancing.
Katrina: 你们的朋友会唱歌吗
Katrina: Do your friends sing?
Lucia:卡拉OK的唱法吗
Lucia: Like karaoke singing?
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Jake:就就就这种唱法
Jake: Yes, exactly like that.
Lucia:不会弹吉他
Lucia: Can't play the guitar.
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina: 不用不用唱
Katrina: No need, no need to play.
Katrina: 到时候反正他有音响
Katrina: We'll have speakers anyway.
Katrina: 直接那个呗
Katrina: Just use that.
Katrina: 唱歌就搞个话筒
Katrina: For singing, just get a microphone.
Katrina: 然后唱歌也可以获得获得
Katrina: And then you can sing and get rewarded.
Alice:可以坐这
Alice: You can sit here.
Alice:我会骑牛
Alice: I can ride a bull.
Alice:正威的唱法
Alice: Sing like Zheng Wei.
Shure: 蓬松的头发
Shure: Fluffy hair.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Katrina: 我们不是合唱吗
Katrina: Aren't we doing a chorus?
Katrina: 是合唱所以在挑两首歌
Katrina: Since it's a chorus, we're picking two songs.
Katrina: 一首就开场欢快一点
Katrina: One for a lively opening.
Katrina: 一首就是适合晚上的慢悠悠的那种
Katrina: And one that's slower, suitable for the evening.
Katrina: 开场的话有听这个
Katrina: For the opening, have you heard this one?
Katrina: 开心超人你听过吗
Katrina: "Happy Hero", have you heard it?
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Shure: 结尾烧好
Shure: Finish it well.
Jake:哈哈哈可拉倒吧
Jake: Hahaha, come on.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 可以整的
Shure: We can do it.
Jake:插点电插点电
Jake: Plug it in, plug it in.
Shure: 给我来一个宝
Shure: Give me a power bank.
Lucia:我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Shure: 给我来个宝
Shure: Give me a power bank.
Shure: 这首歌叫啥来着
Shure: What's this song called?
Tasha:好像就叫朋友吧
Tasha: I think it's called "Friend".
Shure: 啊老男孩
Shure: Ah, "Old Boy".
Tasha:啊对不起
Tasha: Oh, sorry.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 还没唱难忘今宵呢
Katrina: We haven't sung "Unforgettable Tonight" yet.
Katrina: 难忘今宵哎
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight", hey.
Katrina: 我觉得可以
Katrina: I think it's good.
Nicous: 这个好
Nicous: This one is good.
Katrina: 我们还可以采取春晚的那种
Katrina: We can also do it like the Spring Festival Gala.
Lucia:每人唱一句
Lucia: Everyone sings a line.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
修厦:上春山是吧
Shure: Go to the mountain, right?
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: Then...
Lucia:不要再大合唱了
Lucia: No more big chorus.
Katrina: 也行也行
Katrina: That works, that works.
Katrina: 每人唱一句工作量就小一点
Katrina: Everyone sings a line, less workload.
Alice:我有了
Alice: I've got it.
Lucia:17
Lucia: 17.
Jake:17没事多很多
Jake: 17, no problem, plenty more.
Lucia:我信你
Lucia: I trust you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:那给你一个
Jake: Then here you go.
Lucia:没事没事不开玩笑
Lucia: It's fine, just kidding.
Jake:那我给你三个
Jake: Then I'll give you three.
Lucia:行行行用完了我随时换
Lucia: Okay, okay, I'll replace them anytime.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 对但你可以拿双筷子吗
Katrina: Yeah, but can you grab a pair of chopsticks?
Tasha:筷子呢
Tasha: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 哦我需要个宝
Shure: Oh, I need a treasure.
Jake:你给你一个宝
Jake: I'll give you a treasure.
Shure: 谢谢宝
Shure: Thanks, treasure.
Katrina: 海遇恋好像是那个谁的
Katrina: "Hai Yu Lian" seems to be by someone...
Katrina: 很老的一首歌
Katrina: It's a really old song.
Katrina: 你们有推荐的吗
Katrina: Do you have any recommendations?
Katrina: 就是开头比较欢快的
Katrina: Something that starts off cheerful.
Katrina: 你把那几个弹给他们听一遍呗
Katrina: Can you play those few songs for them?
Katrina: 开心超人
Katrina: "Happy Hero."
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone...
Shure: 听过开心超人吗
Shure: Have you heard of "Happy Hero"?
Tasha:no
Tasha: No.
Lucia:那个再见吧妈妈吗
Lucia: Is that "Goodbye Mom"?
Lucia:快乐星球
Lucia: "Happy Planet."
Shure: 什么是快乐星球
Shure: What's "Happy Planet"?
Katrina: 开心超人弹
Katrina: Play "Happy Hero."
Jake:每人拧一个
Jake: Everyone take one.
Lucia:我洗个手
Lucia: I'll wash my hands.
Lucia:我刚从那个啥医院回来
Lucia: I just came back from the hospital.
Lucia:不敢直接接触吃的
Lucia: I don't dare touch food directly.
Katrina: 尝尝
Katrina: Try it.
Katrina: 你这是开心超人的歌吗
Katrina: Is this "Happy Hero's" song?
Shure: 阿里嘎多
Shure: Arigato.
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Ah, yes.
Katrina: 怎么缠着悲悲伤的感觉
Katrina: Why does it sound so sad?
Shure: 我可以把
Shure: I can...
Katrina: 哎哎要怎么吃
Katrina: Hey, hey, how do you eat this?
Tasha:还先蘸这个再蘸这个
Tasha: Dip it in this first, then dip it in that.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Shure: 可是我刚刚舔过来的
Shure: But I just licked it.
Katrina: 哈哈你算了
Katrina: Haha, never mind then.
Tasha:蘸蘸汤
Tasha: Dip it in the soup.
Tasha:蘸蘸再蘸一蘸啊
Tasha: Dip it, then dip it again.
Tasha:然后蘸蘸这个
Tasha: Then dip it in this.
Jake:唉呀妈呜
Shure: 有毒有毒
Katrina: 黏黏的
Shure: 我没蘸东西
Katrina: 我没有词汇量
Katrina: 我太屌了
Jake:我操
Katrina: 香
Alice:轩
Katrina: 嗯轩啊
Alice:轩啊
Shure: 轩哈哈
Katrina: 嗯
Jake:来
Lucia: 这是什么
Jake:嗯来了来了来
Lucia:谢谢嗯嗯
Lucia:年糕吗
Alice:麻薯
Jake:看看这个店
Lucia:这两个是什么味
Lucia: What flavors are these two?
Tasha:豆乳的和可可的
Tasha: Soy milk and cocoa.
Lucia:啊谢谢吃一个
Lucia: Ah, thanks, I'll have one.
Katrina: 他0.5倍速
Katrina: He's at 0.5 speed.
Lucia:可以蘸着吗
Lucia: Can I dip it?
Tasha:要多蘸
Tasha: Dip it a lot.
Lucia:碗都要给我蘸走了
Lucia: I'm going to dip the whole bowl away.
Katrina: 开心往前飞
Katrina: Happy, flying forward.
Katrina: 快点
Katrina: Hurry up.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia:我是不是跟奶油有什么仇啊
Lucia: Do I have some sort of grudge against cream?
Shure: 多少多少学费
Shure: How much, how much is the tuition?
Tasha: :什
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: Huh, what?
Shure: 最重要
Shure: The most important thing.
Tasha:什么不要学费
Tasha: What, no tuition needed.
Lucia:我感觉我又该洗裤子了
Lucia: I think I need to wash my pants again.
Lucia:我好像跟奶油有仇似的
Lucia: It's like I have a grudge against cream.
Tasha:好那给我二成
Tasha: Okay, give me twenty percent.
Tasha:分成吧我亲力教教学
Tasha: Let's split it, I'll teach personally.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm
Lucia:有你去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: If you go to places with a lot of Chinese students, there will definitely be some.
Tasha:他说有没有竞争力
Tasha: He asked if there's any competition.
Lucia:有竞争力啊
Lucia: There is competition.
Lucia:就是去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: Just go to places with a lot of Chinese students, there will definitely be some.
Tasha:那不是有市场吗
Tasha: Isn't there a market for it?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Tasha:不是我的意思是啊
Tasha: No, what I mean is...
Jake:这也没多少
Jake: It's not that much.
Tasha:利润很大
Tasha: The profit is huge.
Jake:没关系不要看了
Jake: It's okay, don't worry about it.
Lucia:我先放一下
Lucia: I'll put it here first.
Tasha:去办一个
Tasha: Get one done.
Lucia:拿瓶水
Lucia: Grab a bottle of water.
Tasha:开家店
Tasha: Open a store.
Lucia:这水应该可以喝吧
Lucia: This water should be drinkable, right?
Lucia:我刚看了
Lucia: I just checked.
Jake:喝喝好的
Jake: Yes, drink it, it's fine.
Lucia:医生让我多喝点水哦
Lucia: The doctor told me to drink more water.
Lucia:我想申请一下这疫苗能报销吗
Lucia: I want to apply for reimbursement for this vaccine, is that possible?
Jake:呃能报能报
Jake: Uh, yes, it can be reimbursed.
Jake:报了
Jake: It's covered.
Lucia:好谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks, thank you.
Lucia:能算工伤吗
Lucia: Can it be considered a work injury?
Lucia:我甚至期待项目结束还得再打两针
Lucia: I might even need two more doses after the project ends.
Jake:啊行行
Jake: Ah, okay, okay.
Tasha:没有去新疆学啊
Tasha: You didn't go to Xinjiang to study?
Tasha:不是这个不是在哪里学
Tasha: No, it's not about where you study.
Tasha:这个没有在哪学
Tasha: It's not about where you study.
Shure: 这不是假的吗
Shure: Isn't this fake?
Shure: 哎呦你这不听
Shure: Hey, you're not listening.
Lucia:万一我今天晚上发烧了的话
Lucia: What if I get a fever tonight?
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:好待会可以
Jake: Okay, later is fine.
Lucia:请大家那个
Lucia: Everyone, please...
Tasha:会发烧的
Tasha: You will get a fever.
Lucia:帮我冻点冰水哈哈哈
Lucia: Help me freeze some ice water, haha.
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia:没有没有应该不会就
Lucia: No, no, it shouldn't be.
Tasha:那不是假的吗
Tasha: Isn't that fake?
Jake:看看你你伤
Jake: Look at you, you got hurt.
Lucia:这个就是他
Lucia: This is him.
Lucia:这就到现在还在红中
Lucia: It’s still red now.
Lucia:看这和这个地方
Lucia: Look at this spot.
Lucia:对现在好像又比我下午好一点了
Lucia: Yeah, it seems a little better than this afternoon.
Tasha:都是假的呵呵呵
Tasha: It's all fake, haha.
Jake:OKOK
Jake: OK, OK.
Lucia:就我特还有点
Lucia:就我确实还有点红然后
Lucia: Yeah, it's still a bit red.
Katrina: 我当时还特崇拜你来
Katrina: I really admired you back then.
Jake:应该还行问题不大
Jake: It should be fine, no big deal.
Katrina: 不是说只只只只是那个店是假的吗就
Katrina: Didn't they say that store was fake?
Lucia:对理论上应该问题不大但是
Lucia: Theoretically, it shouldn't be a big problem, but...
Jake:多打几针几挺好
Jake: Just get a few more shots, it's good.
Lucia:规定是必须要至少要打4次或者5针
Lucia: The rule is at least 4 or 5 shots.
Shure: 哎呀完了腿麻了动不了了
Shure: Ah, my leg's numb, can't move.
Lucia:然后最少最少要打4针
Lucia: At least 4 shots minimum.
Shure: 我靠 哇
Shure: Oh man, wow.
Lucia:就是打5针
Lucia: So, 5 shots.
Lucia:就是28天
Lucia: In 28 days.
Lucia:然后隔多久
Lucia: Then how long in between?
Shure: 我靠动不了你帮我拿一会
Shure: Oh man, can't move, can you hold it for a while?
露西隔一星期打一针
Lucia: One shot per week.
Shure: 我操腿麻了
Shure: Damn, my leg's numb.
Lucia:如果是打4针就是今天要打两针
Lucia: If it's 4 shots, two shots today.
Lucia:对所以我两边都打了一针
Lucia: So, I got one shot on each side.
Jake:我以前也被猫抓了
Jake: I got scratched by a cat before.
Jake:然后我我我是我是在美国住一个LMB
Jake: I was living in an Airbnb in the U.S.
Jake:然后被那边有一只猫抓了
Jake: Got scratched by a cat there.
Jake:然后抓了就
Jake: After getting scratched...
Shure: 没有可乐了
Shure: No more Coke.
Shure: 你的可乐就是我的可乐
Shure: Your Coke is my Coke.
Jake:我和房东房东说打过哦
Jake: I told the landlord, I got scratched.
Jake:然后我我我我也就是
Jake: I was really panicked the first day, but then I didn’t care.
Jake:虽然第一天很慌但是后来也不管了
Jake: Although I was really panicked the first day, I didn't care afterward.
Lucia:对我今天还专门去咖啡馆问了
Lucia: Yeah, today I even went to the café to ask.
Lucia:我说这这小狗有没有疫苗本
Lucia: I asked if the puppy had vaccination records.
Lucia:然后他们说就是就是
Lucia: They said, they said...
Lucia:这个狗现在的疫苗他们还没带去打
Lucia: The dog hasn't been taken for its vaccine yet.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍说打过
Lucia: But the kennel said it was done.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia:但是就是狗舍没有给他们给疫苗本
Lucia: But they didn't give them the vaccination book.
Lucia:然后我觉得啊那要不然回去打一下吧
Lucia: So I thought, maybe we should take it back for the shot.
Jake:还是不够踏实对
Jake: Just to be safe, right?
Lucia:对不对
Lucia: Right?
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia:所以我就
Lucia: So I...
Lucia:然后我问了一下我我那个我家人
Lucia: Then I asked my family.
Lucia:我妈说他朋友养猫
Lucia: My mom said her friend had a cat.
Lucia:然后被自己家猫抓了
Lucia: And got scratched by it.
Lucia:就也去打了
Lucia: So they went for a shot too.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 我说可以去采一个吧
Shure: I said we could go get one.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Tasha: 如果不打的话怎么样
Tasha: What happens if we don't get it?
Lucia:然后我本来想着对
Lucia: So I was thinking...
Lucia:就是我可能很快就打回来了啊
Lucia: Maybe I could get it quickly.
Jake:我之被抓的时候
Jake: When I got scratched...
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake:那种大长狗
Jake: By a big dog.
Jake:那小狗没听就没听见
Jake: The puppy didn't even notice.
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Tasha: 我说如果没有打疫苗得上狂犬病会怎么样
Tasha: I mean, what if you get rabies without the vaccine?
Lucia:我们打算开始之前打算回来了
Lucia: We planned to get it before coming back.
Tasha: 马上死掉
Tasha: Instant death.
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because it's actually quite close.
Tasha:真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Katrina: 百分百致死率
Katrina: 100% fatality rate.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia:对但是那个因为他那是值班嘛
Lucia: But because it was on duty...
Katrina: 如果你得了是前题
Katrina: If you actually get it, that is.
Lucia:然后所以我就要等一下
Lucia: So I have to wait a bit.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 这么恐怖
Tasha: That's so scary.
Lucia:那个医生
Lucia: The doctor...
Lucia:然后我还要再咨询一下他是怎么回事
Lucia: I need to consult with him about it.
Katrina: 那概率还很低
Katrina: But the chances are very low.
Shure: 大家有看到我的手机吗
Shure: Has anyone seen my phone?
Lucia:然后怎么打
Lucia: Then how do we do it?
Lucia:然后所以就稍微晚了一点
Lucia: So we were just a bit late.
Jake:打个电话
Jake: Make a call.
Shure: 嘿Siri换疫苗多少钱一根
Shure: Hey Siri, how much is a vaccine dose?
Jake:那个电话
Jake: That call.
Katrina: 疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is a vaccine dose?
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri.
Katrina: 你那疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is the vaccine dose?
Shure: 在我的iPhone上播放声音算是
Shure: Play a sound on my iPhone.
Lucia:基本上算是100块钱一针
Lucia: It's basically 100 bucks per dose.
Katrina: 哦那还很便宜
Katrina: Oh, that's pretty cheap.
Lucia:对但是要打五针或者四针
Lucia: Yeah, but you need four or five doses.
Lucia:就是打四针的话
Lucia: So if you need four doses,
Lucia:你就是第一天打的时候要打两针
Lucia: you get two on the first day,
Lucia:左右胳膊上各一针
Lucia: one on each arm.
Alice:这个疫苗价钱还不一样的吗
Alice: Are there different prices for vaccines?
Shure: 导航啊
Shure: Navigation.
Lucia:对还有300的哦
Lucia: Yes, there are also 300 ones.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia:但我觉得310只有点太夸张了
Lucia: But I think 310 is a bit too much.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:而且就是
Lucia: And also...
Shure: 你要把所有的全住了
Shure: You have to stay for all of them.
Katrina: 他们的功能不都是抑制吗
Katrina: Aren't they all supposed to suppress?
Katrina: 难道还有什么抑制得快一点
Katrina: Is there one that suppresses faster?
Lucia:好像没啥区别
Lucia: Seems like there's no difference.
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia:应该是没啥区别
Lucia: There shouldn't be any difference.
Alice:他是根据什么来给你选针的呀
Alice: How do they choose the dose for you?
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:这100多跟300多有什么区别啊
Alice: What's the difference between 100 and 300?
Lucia:不知道啊
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia:咱也不知道啊
Lucia: We have no idea.
Alice:我们之前打了
Alice: We had them before,
Alice:就打完一一个就快2,000
Alice: and it was almost 2,000 for one.
Katrina: 定歌定歌定歌定歌定歌
Katrina: Ding ding ding ding ding ding.
Lucia:哦那你可能那
Lucia: Oh, then maybe...
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: because it's actually quite close.
Lucia:那你那那就是你说的这种可能是300一针的
Lucia: So maybe what you had was the 300 per dose one.
Shure: 定歌快快定完歌
Shure: Decide the song quickly, just decide it.
Katrina: 定完歌睡觉了
Katrina: Once we decide the song, we can sleep.
Lucia:如果300多就打完了就是1500对吧
Lucia: If it's over 300, it would be 1500, right?
Shure: 我睡觉觉
Shure: I'm going to sleep.
Alice:那个好像三针
Alice: That one needs three shots.
Katrina: 定完歌写论文哎
Katrina: After deciding the song, I'll write my thesis.
Lucia:三针
Lucia: Three shots.
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Alice:反正我妈去打的
Alice: Anyway, my mom went to get it.
Katrina: 他们要严逼了
Katrina: They are going to get strict.
Lucia:我妈他朋友打的就
Lucia: My mom's friend got it too.
Lucia:也是100块钱一针的
Lucia: It was 100 yuan per shot.
Lucia:然后我觉得这应该就可以了
Lucia: So I think this should be okay.
Jake:OKOKOKOK
Jake: OK, OK, OK, OK.
Katrina: 要不听一下这歌
Katrina: How about we listen to this song?
Katrina: 这应该合唱出来会好听
Katrina: It should sound good as a chorus.
Lucia:希望我今天晚上不要发烧
Lucia: I hope I don't get a fever tonight.
Lucia:医生说常见的副作用是可能会发烧
Lucia: The doctor said a common side effect is fever.
Jake:哦就是打疫苗发烧
Jake: Oh, getting a fever from the vaccine.
Lucia:对打疫苗发烧对
Lucia: Yes, a fever from the vaccine.
Shure: 来先听一下下歌
Shure: Let's listen to the song first.
Shure: 听一下歌
Shure: Listen to the song.
Shure: 这首歌大家听过吗
Shure: Has everyone heard this song?